about time holmes
what's new with senora wells
uh you know she's worried about me
whatever can't help herself you know
checking to see if i'm not riding in
some dumpster like most of the whales
boys
it's really starting to wear on me more
i tell her everything's okay
the more i feel like i'm straight up
lying
but that's done after tomorrow
afterlife here we go baby
we have a ride but nature wins
does not get any higher jim
and you know something else we [ __ ]
earned it man
ready to get your cherry popped yeah
come on
used to be a morgue believe that
really jackie what told you that myself
oh for reals ah [ __ ] that must have been
ages ago
and who might you clowns
we're friends of dexter desean he's
expecting us
yo dex got two live ones saying they're
here to see you
yeah all right then
says he needs a second or two go get
yourself some drinks or something
hey ahead of you yep
sounds
looks like we're up
you see that old lady there that's rogue
best fixer in all the night city thought
dex was the best
rogue was lining up jobs when dex was
still [ __ ] in diapers
the place belongs to her what can i get
you
you two ordered
fashions with a splash of cerveza and a
chili garnish
you have johnny silverhands coming up
right on chica somebody did their
homework
looks like the dog ate mine age old
tradition
drinks are named after our regulars
say i wanted a drink named after me what
would i have to do
snuff it mind-blowingly spectacular
fashion
it up would be best ah what a beautiful
tradition
i guess dying's a small price to pay for
going down in history
i live like a legend first though huh
death
it's nothing but the final flourish
tonight's city and the afterlife
oh and by the way name's jackie wells
you want to write down my recipe hmm
sure shadowback on the rocks
lime juice ginger beer oh and most
importantly
a splash of love ha ha
i'll remember that urging redux his
latest vines
just biz no big deal
mr deshawn see you now break a leg
thanks
this way give us incomplete info again
the [ __ ]
we know how they're geared out big
[ __ ] beans
we got no idea how many you're holding
up in that bunker
jam is
make sure
same here no in the rain you do some
kind of exotic [ __ ]
kenpo
think you could take me drop me
in here
in here
that's right excelsior
cold hard eddies as per usual got a
thousand
well if it ain't mr v oh
family in one place ah finally
first time in real space and the
flathead
let's see this bad boy
all right then set your butts down comfy
sweet booth it's soundproof jackie
now now mr wells is right we're going to
be going over some sensitive material
but if it's all right with y'all i'd
like to start with a question for mr v
evelyn parker how'd you fare
well as i could have i guess walked
around kenpecki plaza inside
from that raw bd she scrolled
bug already filled me in so you know the
target
you're a nobu arisaka the emperor's son
and heir apparent
man with the millionaire name and no
talent to back it up
evelyn parker's special friend so
she just want to see what's good or was
there something else
i think she just wanted to see what i
was about
wanted to see what she was about huh
how about we go over the plan what you
got for us dicks this
well here goes nothing me and dex have
already covered the fine deeds
ops wise should be a stroll on the beach
the library
i want to hear it a delaman will drop
your asses at the front door of kenpecki
plaza
you'll stroll right in thanks to your
false identities
then with bugs help you'll reach the
hotel subnet
mine and the flatheads help last but not
least
you slip into your enubu's penthouse and
clep the relic
it goes without saying we do this on the
hush ideally
no bodies not a one you'll have t-bug on
calms for the duration
time for your burning questions
these new identities tell us more what's
our cover
hello ramon victorino and you're harry
conwell
ramon yeah okay
what do we say we're there for biz as
usual
corporal armsteal case anyone asks you
there for a bogus meeting with our
osaka's defense rep
hajime taki anything else
okay feel brought up to speed perfect
i got a question where do we get to the
real reason we're all here
cut for fresh talent's always the same
and non-negotiable
thirty percent we're all thirty
every part of this drama carries its
risks that's the value of yours as
determined by me
come on dex it's not a little low hey
hold on holmes
look at the flathead who pulled the
intel from the brain dance
and we're going in a hotel full of
soccer men to swipe some [ __ ] toy
from the boss's son
we are the job hmm and who's providing
transport
a top-tier net runner and a leadproof
plan and intel
you sure you want to go down this road
jack's right dex we ought to get more
than 30.
we deserve more fine 35
and that's my final offer i can live
with that
it's my final offer too hmm
been a while since i got a run for my
eddies they're actually kind of fun
last thing kenpecki's got a strict no
iron policy security gates the worst
so you dogs will leave your lead
spitters in the ride take the flathead
inside in its cage
caught some deft suits so you'll look
the part too
oh thanks t so
not to count chickens but why don't we
see our eddies
all depends how miss parker avails
herself of her role
but a week two tops my guess
what do we do while waiting sit around
suck air
you sit tight heads down cause old uncle
arisa could be watching
now as that old greek dog says life's a
banquet so don't go thirsty
don't get drunk either you have cherry
at awaits outside
my cue to delta ii got a prep to jack in
be there when you come on comms
any other issues now's your chance
you and dex know each other a while um
why uh you know people say all kinds of
things
everything we hear is an opinion not a
fact
marcus aurelius i think
you index both philosophizing
no wonder you get along
i'm good no questions let's get to work
so you ready to get going or what
something i got to take care of first
sim problemas
meet you by the dollar bean
just don't forget to suit up
five
is
she cut me off completely
the differences
that boy
anything
so you ready
welcome on board this della main service
with dellamane
you leave your problems at the door
[ __ ]
better [ __ ] believe i will i see no
reason why you should be using
expletives
oh yeah what about that time i wanted to
hire you for my cousin's bachelor party
huh
unfortunately we do not take on such
contracts
three months i'd been saving off scratch
yeah water under the bridge hit it dell
before we begin our journey i must
verify the identities of all customers
please proceed to connect your personal
links
[Music]
thank you excelsior package activated
excelsior oh this just keeps getting
better
excelsior the excelsior is a package
tailored to our premium clientele
top quality don't come free you know now
watch
telemate initiate combat mode my
apologies
but you do not appear to be in any sort
of imminent danger
huh oh well
trust me you'll mow down an army of
psycho ninjas if it comes down to it
dex ain't skimping is he
at least we got some clue where his 65
is going huh
excelsior this is how you want to cruise
into the major leagues
wouldn't get overly excited
haven't gotten there not yet
but no jack kind of feels like you're
losing that steel grip of yours
huh seems to me like it's you've got
some kind of problem
need you to keep your head clear and in
the game we got a job to do
it's never ever been clear in my whole
[ __ ] life
let me explain something to you v
my whole life i've spent in this [ __ ]
around us
and i ain't going back
[Music]
hey how's things smooth as [ __ ]
sandpaper
we'll be uh pulling up to the hotel soon
listen
set up a direct encrypted line to guide
you through kopecki
the ring jackie now see if we're in sync
can't be too careful
we are nearing our destination
and got static say something bug
the greatest crimes issue from a desire
for excess
and not from necessity say what now
aristotle guess you read me then
yeah i read you not so much your greek
friend
though it was kind of exciting could
give it some thought
try to understand how about juvie
read you loud and clear perfect okay
tech checks out looks like
stay in touch thank you for choosing the
della main service
and best of luck i shall wait here for
your return
it's finally happening
almost forgot no iron huh
all right harry let's go morning
night city
hold on let me grab the flathead
papers don't worry got this
welcome to kenpacki plaza please come
through single file
you got it home um sir
hold on got something
care to explain why you're bringing a
combat bot onto kenpecki plaza premises
we're arms dealers excuse me
ah you are here to see takisan am i
right
please accept my apologies for the
confusion
this should only take a moment sir
go ahead
yo crystal greetings and welcome to
konteki plaza we'd like to check in
of course just a moment please
the name on the reservation is
double room two adults one night correct
that's the one perfect i'll go ahead
and notify pakistan over arrival [ __ ] no
good
not part of the plan talk her up v stall
that won't be necessary we'll go freshen
up first
notify him ourselves but
taksang is expecting you no
you know how long we've been traveling
18 hours from new barcelona
with the delay on medicaid because some
cyber cycle blew himself into bits
inside the terminal
oh a nightmare of course i understand
you'll be in the lapis lastly suite on
level 42.
oh one more little formality please
validate your sid chip
hunter's all yours harry
everything seems to be in order we wish
you a pleasant stay
thank you better get going
it's called improvised
all right
what do you think harry hmm
quaint cozy not like the hotel we had in
zurich for that convention
don't need that jack enough
i'm taking this seriously
just who are you anywhere
we don't do reservations weekdays so
feel free to grab any available tables
or a couple of stools at the bar if you
prefer could bring misty here one day
when we uh close this deal
[Music]
you will i'm sure now let's go check out
our digs
you know the part or what how do i look
i can't believe i'm saying this but not
bad at all
yeah i look good in everything
well here we are lapis lazuli
we're in our room pretty snazzy
too bad we ain't stay in the night nice
choice bug
didn't pick it for snazz offers quickest
access to the dweller in servers
now you fire up the flathead and find
the shaft entrance sounds simple enough
simplicity sometimes toughest to master
[Music]
elias aristotle
[Music]
was it this time yours truly
that one's mine where's the shaft boot
up your scanner look around
got a winner
just gonna stand there and look at it
gonna have to switch to manual control
v take the control shirt from jack
here here goes
patching you through the in-cam view
might get a little disoriented but don't
freak
okay got a clear view
you can't just go locking people out of
their home get them to the next man
places of work
on osaka will cover the cost of any and
all penalties assessed
this isn't about the money it's election
season
how do you think this will make me look
people start saying i've lost control of
what
district i'm from a week
that's all we can promise you we will
try
and that is all i can promise you
okay flat heads in patching you into
next cam now
what makes you think it was for you he
addressed it to the kind housekeeper who
finds him
note inside said sorry for the mess
there was blood everywhere a bug
got a smart room panel
might wear expensive suits but he's a
biker at heart
always itching for a ride
i'd give him a ride and wipe him
out honey stick to wiping that glass huh
you're leaving streaks everywhere
uh something's up with the tank
hey bug it worked ain't seen nothing yet
you got any idea how much those things
cost keep moving no time for back patton
[Music]
[Music]
okay dwellers just beyond the door
flathead can jimmy the lock
[Music]
looks like he's having trouble [ __ ]
gotta be another way
let me think got another cam other side
of the door but it's disabled
want me to enable yeah look around for a
cctv report
okay he's at it now toggle over to the
other cam
dwellers inside just as planned still
weird
hotels only got one runner decent
dwellers as good as a dozen rank and
file
flathead ought to be able to neutralize
good thinking
let me graft a demonoid onto your link
and you know you gotta jack the flathead
directly into his chair right
make it sound like i'm new at this okay
scent
he's all yours you'll have to get the
flat head in there first though
shaft may link both rooms looks like
let's figure it out
now toggle over to the other cam might
have found our way in
send the flathead over there then toggle
over to the second cam
flathead into the chair b jack in
got him love those demons flathead stays
right
to keep an eye on the dweller yeah
punching into kompecki's main net you go
ahead and log out
how you feeling fine little dizzy that's
all
bug how you doing on time
you there bug yeah yeah i'm here
so listen ice is thicker than i thought
piercing it'll take a couple hours
a couple hours can't do it any faster
want my brain to burst into flames just
sit down and enjoy your snazzy suite
thanks i will v
you take it easy okay rest up
what do you think why'd he give it all
up
hmm who gave what up you're inobu
arasaka
the good life i mean old news i know
just got to thinkings all it's like
think you've got everything right
at ease education your pops can snap his
fingers and
turn half the [ __ ] planet into a
nuclear wasteland
but instead you're like nah [ __ ] it and
what do you go do
start a [ __ ] gang steal dragons
there's some [ __ ]
it goes from your fam chip some real
skin and
play gang leader for a few years for
what
ah [ __ ] him why do i need to care about
some bougie prick in his street kid
fantasies
must've been a who huh i'm yori nobu
arasaka
would you folks like to join my gang
poser with court protection
and the name too still [ __ ] dragons
oh man a wannabe gang goons wet dream
got bored of being rich and then got
bored of playing tough
[ __ ] tourist tourists or not he just
walked into the lobby
and we are back in biz penthouse
security is neutralized
perfecto let's start the show
i know now's your chance to make up to
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh there's the awkward silence you uh
wanna hear a joke now seriously
okay so why'd the rocker boy's output
kick him out of the apartment
because he wasn't chipping in
jesus christ
guys focus the safe and make it quick
what's the rush sing on your no boo's
gone dark
what is he a [ __ ] sorcerer some kind
of dead zone's my guess have it back in
a sec
and you do your damn job
bingo got something ejected come here v
looks like jorinobu left us a parting
gift hey much
here we go
hurry up v
you got that weird-ass lizard that ain't
no lizard
you said why not you twit check in your
personal and make us rich
[Music]
your turn bug give me two
got wing visitors bug don't know who
but staff's a buzz all 200 on their feet
can't keep still
i can't say i like this
how much longer [ __ ] you're a no boost
pit house bound
[ __ ] him open the shave almost got it
done
let me look to this huh relic intact
bioshard integrity 100
i'm guessing that's a yes good let's go
[ __ ] too late your noble's about to walk
in find cover
where that pillar try that you're
[ __ ] kidding
no inside it now
we're in which don't solve our problem t
i [ __ ] know our problem's still there
let me think for a sec okay
we wait are they here yet they approach
from the landing pad
[ __ ] are they talking about bug who
got incoming no [ __ ] way
this isn't happening
this could be soundproof
[Music]
[Music]
mother
[Music]
too close vida sniffed us out
but he did it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it's
[Music]
i wish i wish
attention code red has been initiated
throughout kenpecki plaza
please remain in your rooms and follow
all instructions given by staff
foreign
[Music]
what the [ __ ] just happened in there
[Music]
what
you know what this means security's
gonna swarm the place any second
oh my god we're so [ __ ]
bug need you get us out of here now give
me a sec
we don't have a sick [ __ ] okay
got something window now
[Music]
releasing the lock should see a ladder
oh [ __ ] oh no no no no not now
just lost [ __ ] [ __ ] made you leaks
happy now jackie
check around the bench
check around the bench
yeah that's [ __ ] high
[ __ ] that drama if they're here for
saburo
they're a little late
let's hope they didn't see us
[Music]
oh [ __ ] because
the relic madres
oh this ain't good
jackie you're bleeding worry about me
later
kept the relic container depressurized
mild chip integrity at 94 percent
you [ __ ]
parker call her and tell her we fried
the case
just do it
what the [ __ ] is going on there got a
problem
cryo case is damaged biochips integrity
add
jackie 86 percent
86 and drop it
that doesn't sound safe the longer you
wait the greater the risk will lose it
well someone's gotta do it
[Music]
you okay
no no i guess don't feel any different
we'll take out the relic and run a full
brain scan and sweep
but you two need to get the [ __ ] out of
there first we're working on it
dale we'll be there in a couple
be ready got it certainly mr wells
better be [ __ ] certain
now we must be quick
look what i see great now let's get out
of here
attention code red has been initiated
throughout your kentucky plaza
clear please remain understood over and
out
i ain't got time for this was a drill
why they sending soccer special forces
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
has been evacuated what's going on there
doesn't sound good
my staff
hmm
for the third consecutive year militech
has been touted as
night city's best corporation to work
for
this prestigious award
such as five paid vacation days a year
unlimited access to stimulant
pharmaceuticals
and implant acquisition assistance
did you check the zen rooms yesterday
[Music]
they got eyes on this turf careful
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
hmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
um
[Music]
ain't doing too bad just a little
further
surrender immediately
uh
given by staff
almost got me
uh we're being attacked
cover me
okay
point for you
[Music]
neutralize him let's go
go go go
he's wounded
he's
oh
out of my work on you
[ __ ]
go go
go go
50 bags
john shoot
down
enemy contact i'm engaging
waiting keep
nice job hey gotta start at security
clearance
[ __ ]
save your strength
tell bug why don't you maybe she'd still
be alive and he hadn't been so
gung-fucking ho
don't take this out on me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
go go
shoot
need to reload
uh
he's
mark
focus
he's in here somewhere
i advise that you waste no time in
entering the vehicle
go go
i'm perfect
how's our ride looking tip top though
alas
we are being pursued
please remain calm oh
leave it at me
[Music]
uh
[Music]
phew
we did it jackie we [ __ ] made it
i guess we did my medical diagnostics
indicate that mr wells's condition is
critical
then step on it i am doing what i can
you've got to hold tight jackie you hear
me
of course i suggest you try to keep mr
wells conscious
it's gonna be all right huh you'll see
misty your mom
everyone you love jackie don't close
your eyes
misty hush
you always knew
for me
[Music]
mr wells has passed where shall i take
his remains
what the excelsior package provides for
the disposal of passenger remains free
of charge
i merely require a destination
vic vector will take care of him his
family shouldn't see him like this
of course understood mr deshawn awaits
you in room number 204
seeing the major leaks jack
oh
[Music]
so
he waiting
wns n54
even the pirate networks you blowing up
everywhere and the jackster
he out in the car
yeah he's there dead
head of the japanese mega corporation
was reported
that's one piece of good news good news
dad you got any notion of the [ __ ] you
pulled me into
you off the [ __ ] emperor his majesty
anyone with so much as a pinky toe
dipped in this mess is as good as dead
i know and that's why we gotta skip
night city dex
you're the fixer all right settle down
gotta be tactical about this
new place new identity but first
your face got blood all over it
bathroom's there go get yourself cleaned
up
[Music]
[Music]
so
green risky v remember our first convo
that seems like what the [ __ ] the client
life after all
no blaze of glory for me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey